Okay, that was great. Hi everyone, super
excited to be here. I'm Mark, one of the
founders of LangFuse.
We started LangFuse like 3 years ago
when everything was felt quite early.
Building agents that didn't work and
then realized, "Okay, there needs to be
like some evaluation tracing." Built
like LangFuse is the open-source project
in the space by now. And with the
metrics that we track, we seem to be the
largest one in the space. We do our
product engineering out of Europe. Thus,
I'm very excited this conference is
coming to Europe because there are so
many great people here.
And we always need to resist the urge to
like ship the whole team to another
continent because actually being here is
very nice.
And you can just travel and hang with
people on Discord and Zoom. So, yeah,
very excited to be here in person. And
what I want to talk about today is how
what the lessons we made from scaling up
coding agents actually adding LangFuse
to an application because like back in
the days when you had like observability
or evals, you needed to read like
hundreds of pages of docs, like figure
out your own mental model. And now you
kind of expect like to be hand-holded by
a custom agent to do this. And we've
come a long way in achieving this kind
of vision. And I just want to explain
what we learned on the way. First of
all, like I'll start very conceptual,
very easy, then a bit more conceptual
deeper, and then I'll do go to the
learnings. So, my mental model for
skills is just like I get this Rubik's
Cube. When I was a kid, I didn't have no
idea what to actually do, but I mean, I
basically have a bash tool. I can do
whatever I want with this Rubik's Cube,
but it just looks colorful in different
ways. I had no idea how to solve it. So,
skills was like a great way once you get
the manual, it's easy. You just need to
follow the manual, and you can you can
solve a Rubik's Cube. And I feel like
the same thing now applies to to agents
where like there was this whole debate
of like workflow versus fully autonomous
agent. It was like huge fight on X of
like what is the best way to build an
application. Everyone was kind of like,
"Yes, you kind of both." And I think
Mars this morning had like a good note
where like the surface area of deploying
agents is so broad that like for some
you don't need like a coding agent even
if it's like the best way you can build
agents at the frontier today. Like you
don't need this for every application.
It makes things slow, expensive, and
like there's this kind of like balance
between workflow being very reliable and
agent now having kind of like unlimited
capabilities. And I think what's very
exciting is that then skills are kind of
like a formalized shortcut to make
things more reliable where you
historically would have built a
workflow. Like I don't know. Like you
have a customer like customer support
agent and someone asked for like a
password reset. Then historically you
would have built like a workflow that's
very reliable of like you have a router
that routes to like an agent that can
only do password resets and that agent
has like the context to do password
resets well.
That was great, but also if the user
then wants to do password reset but also
change the email address at the same
time, then like the router is kind of
like, "Okay, I have this email router. I
have this password reset router. What
what do I even do?" And I think what's
very exciting now is that an agent can
just like progressively get the context
needed to then solve like a problem
that's multi-domain. Like that would
have historically been in multiple
workflows. So that's very exciting.
However, it has always been hard to kind
of like how to how to build an agent,
what kind of use cases even exist
because you have like this open-ended
text input box often or like open-world
context. So you didn't really know. So
what we now see is what many teams do is
they have the agent runtime, they trace
everything. I mean, I'm building
LangFuse this I put my logo here but you
can also use whatever you want. In the
end it's more about like the concept of
tracing is what you need to like
identify what happens at runtime when a
trace when like an agent executed
because then it helps you two things.
One, like new kind of like use cases
that you didn't expect a user to do
because you might have expected that
nobody ever wants to change a password
but now they want to change the
password. This you need to see the
execution trace of someone being upset
by like a production email to then
derive that you need to add a skill for
handling password resets well.
And two, once you have these skills they
can get out of date or you can realize
they're not the most efficient way of
actually solving for this use case. So
it's like the second thing of like
helping you improve skills that you
already have in your agent.
So, this is very conceptual, but this is
what we what we now see see most teams
do uh that you use LangFuse now more
towards like the learnings uh we made uh
when building a skill to help uh
customers add LangFuse to their project.
So, what was the lay of the land before
we got started with this? Um like 478
pages of documentation. Whenever I see
like the thing deploying, I'm like, "Who
wrote all of this?" So, apparently, if
you build a project over 3 years, it
just grows in complexity. People can do
all of these different things, but then
you need to read all of these things,
and nobody has the time across like five
different feature areas, and a lot of
implementation flexibility because
they've always been like projects in
like the eval space that were very, I'd
say,
opinionated. So, they were like, "Oh,
you have a chatbot? Then add this
project, and it'll just solve this for
you opinionated end-to-end." We always
were like, "No, no, we are
infrastructure. We do like tracing well.
Like, if you ingest like billions of
traces, we'll still work. If you want to
customize your evals, it'll still work."
So, we always take more on the
opinionated side. Uh which was always,
I'd say, uh a weakness compared to uh
projects that are more opinionated, but
now I think it's a strength because in
the end, what what what what do you need
uh when agents do all of this? You only
need the infrastructure piece if agents
can then customize for different
workflows. Um so, uh but there's the
problem if people want to add LangFuse
to a project, how to do it correctly for
a project is to be figured out by an
agent. Um and uh interestingly, uh when
we first got into model pretraining
context as a project, and you can just
ask an agent how to add LangFuse, and
it'll spit out like LangFuse SDK logic.
The first time this happens, it's
amazing. But then, if you're like 2
years in, like the project evolves, like
interfaces change, uh and now being in
pretraining context might even be like a
disadvantage if uh you don't fetch
up-to-date information. So, we're just
like, "Oh, we get like all of these
hallucinations of methods that have been
uh available in the past, but they're
not uh available there today." So, yeah,
we we felt like when skills launched,
this is like the exact pattern that we
need in order to help teams achieve
this.
So, I'll use an example uh when you just
ask Cloud Code to add a language to a
project, it just worked, but it was not
working in the best way possible. So,
for example, user ask add tracing to my
agent and then Cloud Code kind of like
implements the instrumentation based on
the outdated pre-training context, then
tries to verify whether tracing works,
then realize, "Oh, it doesn't work." And
then only in a second step fetches
up-to-date information to then correct
the issue. At the same time, how you add
tracing or evaluation to a project, they
can evaluate in like like gazillion
different ways. Like online evals,
offline evals, human in the loop. There
are so many different things. And often
the question is like, "What even is
relevant for your application?" So,
human agent kind of need to figure it
out on the way, but agent is not tasked
to help you like figure out what's the
best thing for your for your
application. So, main problems are
outdated training data, the non-optimal
setup because the agent wasn't really
like primed to help you discover what to
do for your for your app. And it's very
slow because you first add
instrumentation the wrong way, then you
figure out it's wrong, and then you need
to fetch more documentation to to fix
the the issues.
So, what did we do? Ah, yeah, this how
the this how I just mental mental note,
this how the trace look like when we
just tried with Cloud Code to like just
trace two LM calls in an agent, but like
you still don't know what the agent is
actually doing.
So, what was the goal of our skill? Like
give every LangChain user, like there
are thousand of teams in the community,
thousand of customers on our cloud
product, give them all like a LangChain
expert to help them quickly set up
observability, for mentionment, evals in
line with like best practices and
up-to-date docs and like references.
Because all of you, I mean, there's
Anabel from the team here as well. Like
if you have questions regarding
observability evals, you can talk to us,
but in the end that doesn't scale to a
thousand of people to basically talk
through your problems and figure out
what the best strategy is for you. So,
we are like, "Okay, skills is the is the
way to go." And this is like very
conceptual how our skill works where
like user comes in, ask coding engine to
do something, and then the skill kind of
has like a reference of like the skill
MD is more like well, what kind of style
do we want in order to implement
LangFuse? So, for example, ask follow-up
questions before making decision because
there's so much you can be doing, and
then references for the different
product modules to kind of like
progressively disclose additional hints
that the agent might need to have. And
then it can call the documentation, and
interesting enough, as we start open
source and like saw ourselves as like an
opinionated infrastructure, we always
had like APIs for everything because
teams built their own, I don't know, on
labeling UIs on top of it, on evaluation
execution logic on top of our our back
end. And we had APIs for everything. Now
we wrapped it in a CLI, and now an agent
can just do everything humans needed to
do in the UI in the past.
Which is very cool because like so many
teams spent so many hours every week in
clicking around in our UI to evaluate
and improve the application. And in the
end, how will this look like end of
year? It'll probably just be like like
connect repository to LangFuse, and then
agent just does the whole thing like
auto-regressively. I mean, that's what
we're building towards. Everyone's
building towards. I think that's a cool
step in the right direction.
So,
to to shortcut to the end result, okay,
after like conversing with the agent now
for the for similar thing, it looks way
more detailed like
like detailed evals that are relevant
and detailed steps are regarding tool
execution.
So so just like there's there's a stark
difference. And yeah, what did we learn
on the way? Six main things. I'll go
through every single one of them
of what were basically our realizations
when when building the skill. And like
one, looking at traces still like gets
you to like 80% of the detail. This was
always what we kind of like tried to
preach regarding like evals where many
people try to complicate things right
away while they haven't dig through
through like just like what did the
agent actually do at runtime themselves
a couple of times. So so what did we do?
We have instrumentation for cloud code
and just ourselves interactively
like tried to use LangFuse with cloud
code and then look through traces in
length use to understand whether there
is an error, how can we improve the
skill to make it like straight shooting
at the goal instead of like wandering in
different ways to the to the target. And
that was really helpful, too.
There were like some of the interesting
learnings here.
For example, for humans, we tried to cut
down on the number of environment
variables that you need to set in order
to set up length use. So, for example,
we just auto assumed a data region.
Like, length use is available in Europe,
it's available in the US. Funny
anecdote, we assumed that only Europeans
like care about data regions, so we made
Europe the default. Then we learned some
US enterprises also care about data
regionality. Now we have a US data
region, so many different other data
regions.
So, we always defaulted to Europe, and
now we kind of like for an agent like
adding another environment variable,
like they don't care. Like, it's not
effort for them. Thus, we always prompt
for figure out what data region the user
is actually in and don't assume Europe,
for example. Two, hallucinated CLI
parameters because it just oh, this like
includes the word trace. I've seen trace
things in CLIs before. I just assume
what what we could be doing here. And we
just advertise the the help flag more
aggressively.
It takes another turn, but it's fast,
and thereby like it directly knows what
the CLI can do.
Two,
we try to help the agent understand how
to navigate available information
because like I mean, 500 documentation
pages, how to find the right one instead
of like looping through, I don't know,
fetching one, then learning something,
then fetching another one, always with
like thought process in the meantime.
So, what did we do? We always had this
LLM stakes see, which was very hyped
when it launched, but never actually
used. I think what's now cool is we have
this agent sitemap kind of that we just
expose to
like a coding agent by the skill of like
go there first in order to learn what
kind of like documentation is available.
And two, I mean, there's like this whole
content negotiation that if you send
like an a request header that you want
markdown that you get markdown back from
the docs, but some coding agents don't
do this by default. So, we just
advertise this because otherwise some
coding agents might try to pass the
HTML, which just adds additional tokens.
So, like for length use, for example,
you can just add like a dot MD to any
documentation page or you can request
markdown and you'll get a markdown page.
Uh three,
um I think that was uh like one of the
things I was most excited about. Uh we
always had this uh like docs Q&A agent
that was able to answer questions about
LangFuse more like interactively.
Therefore, we built like a rec stack and
now we just surface this uh rec stack
again via like a search endpoint. So,
like a coding agent can just ask
whatever natural language query about
LangFuse and we'll get back
documentation chunks for this query. Why
is this exciting? One, you don't need to
fetch five different docs page where you
can just ask a question, get something
back that's relevant directly. It solved
for the problem and two, we get to track
these search parameters
um because uh like if a coding agent
fetches documentation, it's very
difficult to understand what did like
cloud code and our user laptop do. But
if they um ask questions about LangFuse
to our search endpoint, we can track the
searches and thereby understand what
problems do they run into, where do we
need to add more documentation pages
because maybe we didn't expect this kind
of problem to happen. So, yeah. So,
adding a search endpoint was like was
really cool to um capture more data.
Um then uh basic eval setup is better
than none because we initially struggled
to get this done because it's like so
broad. Some LangFuse users built like
chat applications, real-time voice,
video generation, like batch processing
of like invoices in the background of
some kind of like text uh software. Like
so many different use cases where then
the question is, what's even like a good
evaluation uh like setup? And we just
created like five uh different ones and
this was already helpful. Um because
otherwise uh it's really hard to uh to
kind of like measure measure anything.
And what we did here, um I don't know,
can I zoom in? No.
Um so, basically we have this uh like
just like a prompt instrument
application with LangFuse and then like
a sample uh repository folder. So, for
example, like an OpenAI custom function
rec, whatever, application. And our
checks are just natural language
statements that we then via LLM as a
judge try to um like evaluate on top of
the file system and diff state
before and after um running the skill.
Uh so, for example, we uh we expect that
our open eye instrumentation was added
because they can open the eye example.
And we, because it's rag, we
expect like some retrieval spans to show
up in our trace. Because if they if
they're no retrieval spans, then
probably we only capture, for example,
LM calls.
This was already helpful because there
we were able to make changes and see
that we didn't break anything. The whole
thing that why why we even built
LangFuse for like building AI agents now
also applies here.
Five, dynamic content should be
referenced because there's a huge, I'd
say, incentive for like developers on
the team, but also for users in the
community to just contribute a lot of
context to the skill because then you're
like, "Ah, it's kind of like a local
cache of the documentation that's
immediately available." However, then
the same thing applies that applies to
pre-training context. It's kind of like
it goes out of date. And now we have the
documentation and now we have yet
another representation of what LangFuse
is. So, you rather try to point us to
straight to the reference of
documentation and because otherwise you
just duplicate all our content. And six,
we applied I'm more of like auto
research to the scale of, "Okay, if we
have a target function, how can like
agents help us improve the agent?"
Because there are so many like different
patterns that we can explore.
So, we set up a target function mostly
geared towards like our experiment here
was help teams move prompts from their
local Git repository into LangFuse
prompt management, which is used by like
larger teams to collaborate on prompts
with their non-engineering counterparts
because then like PMs can make changes
to prompts and try it on a playground
like all this kind of like collaborative
stuff. And the task was, "Okay, how do
we improve the skill to migrate prompts
out of any kind of like code base into
our managed prompt system?" And
in the end, we accepted three out of the
six improvements that were suggested,
which I think is a success.
But it allowed us to experiment much
more than we could have explored
manually with the time that we have as
we are like a very small team.
Learnings,
like the target function really matters.
Like I think it's it sounds obvious, but
for us defining like the right target
function was very hard for this. Um this
we we assumed like a trunk migration
should be fast. Fast we measured in like
the number of turns, but if we uh
basically asked to minimize the number
of turns, then like our uh like the
agent that tried to optimize the scale
just took out all of the notes that we
had to um like fetch documentation
because it was like, "I know how to how
lengthy this prompt management works. I
don't need this. I'll just try it
myself." Uh which then negates the whole
thing of we want to fetch up-to-date
context because otherwise if you use the
skill install the skill once, wait 3
months, then you'll have like wrong
context um because uh we duplicate
information. Two, um like we had like an
approval gate usually uh where we want
to suggest a plan or ask for a question
suggest plan to a user before doing
anything because we kind of like push
the prompts to like a central repository
and it's kind of like their data leaving
their laptop somewhere else.
Um but the sandbox didn't have this, so
we didn't really we weren't really able
to uh to to try for this. And um like
LangChain like the the sole feature like
usually we try to make it easy to get
going with something, but then it's very
deep of how to do it in a good way. And
we want agents to directly go for the
good way like figure out with the user
what they want to achieve and then have
like a very full implementation not to
start with something and then like 2
months later go deeper.
However, if the target function does not
include uh like we want like uh linking
prompt versions to prod traces, so then
you can see how like different prompt
versions impact like for example
production results. Um like we didn't
have this in the target function. This
uh like uh everything that like nudged
towards this was kind of like removed
because it's kind of like it's just like
like garbage on the way that we don't
need to achieve the goal. So again, the
target function really matters.
High level, these were like the the six
uh main takeaways. Looking at traces
gets you 80% of the way. The uh
production signals really helps, so the
search endpoint uh was really helpful
for our documentation. Um
help agents to navigate uh the
information because otherwise it just
searches with like Google, Brave,
whatever search and finds all sorts of
different things on the internet. Um
even a basic even setup helped. It
wasn't that hard to set up. Dynamic
content should be referenced, otherwise
you have just duplicates, and the auto
research was uh very helpful to explore
things, but um it's bound by the target
function.
Um topics basically on our minds here
are uh it's so powerful, but at the same
time, you kind of then duplicate stuff
into like user space kind of like
somewhere on on like a machine.
Um like there's no like package
management for this, which then like a
year like tells the user this is
outdated. Um like we could uh we we we
thought about just adding like a
timestamp of uh this is the current date
where it was fetched uh the skill, uh
and then just uh oh, if this like older
than a month, then try to update. But
then we go to second problem of skill
distribution and like installing into
like the agent environment. Usually,
this is kind of like gated or not
possible for the agent like depending on
uh what you use.
Um this user needs to do something to
install the skill. This also upgrading
doesn't uh auto upgrading doesn't really
uh really work, but it really depends on
the coding agent that you use. And uh
like the target function is interesting
for us because like we can either go for
user needs to get to like an initial aha
of like oh, this works, or do we want to
directly straight shoot for this is the
perfect setup of how you would do evals
for this use case? But this is I mean,
without a skill, it takes like usually
like an AI engineering team, it takes
like months to get to a perfect setup.
Do we now aim for an agent to do this in
a single shot and overload the user with
lots and lots of questions, or do we
just try to get to something and then
you can still invoke it again of like
improve my setup, ask and then it it can
ask questions to improve it. So, it's
kind of like well, what's what's the
target for the skill? That was uh very
interesting for us.
Uh yep, I would invite you to try it and
give us feedback um because that would
be really interesting. Um and uh
like uh we do lots of lots of calls with
people from the community every week,
and uh like like uh I think it's not a
surprise that I think nobody reads
documentation themselves, and everyone
is just like, "Yeah, just add this to my
like I just want this to work. Like just
add it." Um so, yeah, the skill is the
primary way of how things get done. This
is also like now the advertised way
across all of our documentation um that
you just should ask your coding agent to
do whatever you try to do right now. Um
I'm very excited that works really well,
uh but also I'm I'm excited to see what
what comes next. Um for us as a project
roadmap-wise, we see the skill right now
like our users use this when getting
started with the project, but also um uh
to drive a lot of automation around the
like evaluation life cycle of oh I now
want to create like an element as a
judge that's aligned with user
preferences or um like I got user
feedback on 100 different executions,
what do they have in common? And you
just then fetch this via the CLI. So
many of these workflows that people
needed to do manually now coding agents
do for them.
Um we'll bring this in product via like
we will help automate this via skills
one, bring this in product two, and then
three I I feel like we just need this
orchestration agent that does what the
team is doing right now. So yeah, I'm
very excited for our roadmap to to
automate all of this, but yeah if you
have any feedback, uh I'm around,
Anabel's around. I would love to talk to
you. Uh and yeah, thanks so much FOR
YOUR TIME.
I DON'T KNOW DO WE HAVE TIME FOR A
QUESTION? OKAY.
YEP.
UH YEAH, it was kind of um like I mean
you kind of want to be out of the loop
for the experimentation and then just
review the suggested changes. Uh so it
was kind of um like experimental things
uh give us like all sorts of different
recommendations and then human review
the suggestions. Like we didn't accept
all because many didn't make sense
because our target function wasn't
perfect. It was really difficult to get
to like a very perfect target function,
but it's good at just creating ideas and
then uh we human reviewed all of the
ideas to make the changes to the skill.
>> But so at the end the skill might not be
optimizing for
>> Yeah, that's what we had tried to kind
of like you need to try it yourself to
just get a sense of how it feels to use
the skill to then
like like add slightly student
application. So we just use it ourselves
to get a sense for the feeling because
it should like where where you want to
go is it should feel like
an expert user
trying to guide you through what you
need for your problem where usually
someone comes in with just like I need
eval because I read about it online but
I don't know what actually I need for my
application and I kind of like it needs
guidance of where you want to go like
what is your problem? I don't know what
you what you worry about. You probably
don't need like a I don't know
hallucination eval but probably need
something that's very specific to your
application and
yeah, that's what we want to achieve
with the skill that you get like some
some like professional guidance.
Yep.
>> I really resonated with your last point
about
skills distribution seems
practically insane right now or just
like you just install it whatever you
get
what are your thoughts on sort of like
the
treating skills as packages like a big C
skills kind of approach or like going to
pull all in on and you know plug in
marketplaces instead like what
what do you think is
able to be adopted by the community
versus
being stable long term and you have like
prominent set of things.
>> Mhm.
As a small team I'm not that excited
about plug-in marketplaces because then
you need now need to kind of like
maintain all of these proprietary
integrations, update them and I don't
know tell Anthropic, tell OpenAI, tell
Cursor whenever you make them.
Yeah,
still I mean like for the skill
I think it would be cool if we just had
like a well-known skill or something and
like whenever someone is like oh I want
to for example use LangFuse like the
agent can just auto discover that
exists. Uh like we have it across all of
our docs, so I think it would be enough
if agent can kind of like ask user I
want to install skill. Question is do
you even need to ask? Like I think you
only need to ask if the skill is kind of
like more trusted than the public web.
If it's like same trust level, then why
even bother asking? Um and then two is
kind of like if I have this installed,
there's kind of like a cache of
something that was up-to-date when it
when I install it. But then the question
is how do I know whether it's out of
date? So I think so just like time
stamping it is enough. So when you use
the skill, that agent can be like, "Oh,
this seems old. I should probably like
fetch a new one."
Um I think this would already go a long
way. Um
but yeah, I'm excited to see like we are
going more the time stamp fetch a route
or alert user of this might be out of
date. Uh that's at least like what we
discussed now.
Um but yeah, I'm excited to see what
everyone's shipping in this space.
Yeah, I'm around. Uh thanks so much.
Bye-bye.